we're going to begin this hour with a
final Act of an icon of ballet as we
celebrate Black History Month Virginia
Johnson's career in dancing began as the
principal ballerina with a legendary
Dance Theater of Harlem back in 1969 and
for the last 12 years she has served as
its artistic director after an amazing
four decades did you hear that part four
decades at the dancer of Harlem she's
finally hanging up her ballet shoes CBS
Saturday morning co-host that's Michelle
Miller career caught up with Johnson at
the company's New York Studio rather to
look at her Trail blazing life
at this stage of her career Virginia
Johnson is teacher when you go assembly
back you have to and then you go to the
next place we have to see that change in
your head as well interpreter no it's
not that one that was very good and the
backbone of an historic institution
they're the longest legs in the universe
you have to send them out hours ahead of
a performance in Houston the 73 year old
is taking in every bit of the last four
decades before she steps down in June
what kept you here this long why did you
stay here I felt very much a sense of
mission as being part of Dance Theater
Harlem I stayed also because I had an
amazing career
her passion for ballet started at the
age of three I fell in love with it
right away
it was just so much fun and I could see
myself as a ballerina but few spaces
existed for people like her it wasn't
until
1969 when ballet Pioneer Arthur Mitchell
founded the dance theater of Harlem that
she would find a home the thing about
Dance Theater of Harlem and Arthur
Mitchell right from the start
it was magnificent from the beginning
that first group of people and there
were six other dancers who were there in
1969 when we were Incorporated
each one of us had been told no you
can't do this no you do not belong it
was born in the wake of Dr Martin Luther
King Jr's assassination
[Music]
with diversity and inclusion its primary
mission in a ballet world where it was
mostly absent certainly for the black
community having the answer to Harlem
was a validation of the the right the
properness of us our being in this art
form it hasn't always been a smooth
Landing for the company the company
faced all kinds of obstacles right from
the start
our first years black people didn't want
us to do ballet and why people didn't
want us to do ballet why didn't black
people want you to do ballet do the
white man's art form
why should we be doing that in 2004
mounting debt shut down the company for
eight years retired from dancing Johnson
returned in 2011 to revitalize dth as
its artistic director telling important
sometimes tough stories through ballet
as with its current piece Higher Ground
which showcases the frustrations and
joys of being black in America to Stevie
Wonder songs from the 1970s I think the
thing that has been the fire that kept
us going was belief in the power of art
to transform
Misty Copeland one of today's most
accomplished ballerinas said without
Virginia Johnson she would not be where
she is
Johnson's Legacy continues to feed those
in her care working with her is really
inspiring especially in this ballet that
I get to do the principal role that was
her place amazing rewarding and fun hey
it ain't a bad gig what's most fun for
you guys well I love the touring aspect
of dth because we get to go out and
really teach people about ballet for the
first time but I also just love our
environment here but you have to figure
out what how you want to turn your
shoulders so for the next few months she
will continue her craft mentoring this
generation the indefinable part of being
an artist exists without words so what
are you looking for I'm really really
looking for dancers with imagination
it's what they think they're doing what
they want to show us if you have
imagination you can transcend being
flesh and blood and you can show them
I'm a sparkling Diamond I'm a wisp of
air and that's what you bring to the
movement when you look back back on your
career what can you say you've been most
proud of oh perseverance
that I just kept going and regardless of
any obstacles that came
between me and that future that I kept
going we know that we are on a mission
to change this form but we also love it
and the more we love it the more we can
do it as she gets ready to move into her
next chapter the mission remains ballet
belongs to everyone
for CBS mornings Michelle Miller New
York
I looked at that piece and I want to say
Virginia Johnson please don't leave
please don't leave oh my gosh what a
career what a life she's had and I look
at her legs she and Misty Copeland a
ballerina's legs to me are like works of
art and you see what she was doing back
in the day it's really beautiful and I
like when when Michelle said what are
you most proudest of she didn't stutter
did she personally she didn't hesitate
perseverance ballet belongs to everybody
but being a ballet dancer is for the few
and the strong yes exactly well said